do you have to renew your license at all
like to for like a beauty license every
how often every two year and what's the
test like I do 15 minutes of sex
trafficking and then you got to do 5
hours of just continue education would
you say sex trafficking M
okay this you're going to have to give
what the chasm between white and black
Americans is growing wider with each
passing day our views culture General
outlook on like are so different that
even living in the same Community
sharing the same space is something
that's almost unfeasible at least that's
what you'd believe if you're an avid
consumer of Legacy Media trust should
not be dled out easily to anyone
especially white people here's the thing
I've noticed and and you can comment if
this is the same for you it doesn't
match up at all with my lived
experiences and that's what's inspired
me to actually do what the likes of
these Legacy Media Outlets refuse to do
get out into the community and have real
conversations with average Americans
black Americans white Americans not
caricatures of what the media thinks
black
people people like van Jones I I was I
was shaking listening to him talk in the
latest installment of this series I made
my way to a cultural mainstate in modern
black American society the barber shop
because really what better place to find
authentic unfiltered perspective than
the place that's iconically known as the
breeding ground for conversation in the
black community do you think webly get
it
that's that's man and what did I find
are black and white Americans as far
apart from each other as we've been told
well see for yourselves this is black
and white on the gray
issues you know what it is it's white
bites I'm not going to
lie oh I don't give a you're good with
these two right here it's white
women okay let me ask you this has there
ever been a group of
people that has had it better than white
and yes I mean white women not even
white men white women in the 21st
century who complain
more think about it everything it's like
they they have all the benefits of being
like a protected class but they're also
just white people so you know they just
everything is a complaint and those are
the ones who always get offended like
you saw at SMU they come like you can't
say that what the hell and that's how
that started like I would say like
that's racist what's racist say that
black people make better comedians like
have you heard of Richard like that's a
that's a compliment like I'm a comic
like you can't say that that's a
stereotype they say it for black people
white women you're like you just shut up
some people always just want to be heard
and be seen say saying a lot but not
saying anything at all I know you know
so it it's it's
a white women white
people you know they have it easy it's a
lot like that I'm not that type of dude
but white people do have it e but white
women absolutely I absolutely agree with
you I'm I'm Terri you know what this me
was or is I've been sitting at a light
downtown Dallas yeah and some people uh
I walk by they lock their door yeah it's
like man I I
have nothing I I I would do nothing
anything to you but just to be they to
the tear drop and think that means you
somebody you got to give them that but
I'm not I'm not guy unapproachable
though I know that means he's been
initiated I saw Grant Torino I know how
this
ends yeah I don't think I don't think
that's great specific right there you
just see that and you kind of like shift
to the no yeah like I I tell you what if
if like if I didn't know post Malone and
I was driving I would lock my doors you
know I'd hide my cocaine D godamn I
ain't got all this my face well I mean
that's why it makes it stand out more
though because it's like you're making a
statement
like you see
this cuz if someone has like a bunch of
tattoos you just think they're a hipster
you know what I mean but the teardrop
you think
like well cuz I come from I was raised
in Montreal um where the crazy thing is
people don't realize like the biker
gang's there um 100 I think it was 116
people were killed in the decade from
biker gangs uh like the biker gangs from
the here they like we won't send the
Hell's Angels but we're not going to
send anyone out to Montreal anymore
they're incredibly violent because they
have the ports that everything comes
into through the ports in Montreal
before it gets to New York and so people
kind of know there it's not like a
teardrop tattoo but if you see that like
three-piece rocker you just it's it's a
sign they're letting you know so it's
the same thing in certain areas in the
states right if they see like in LA if
you see a tear drop for sure I mean I
lived in Englewood for a while if I saw
teardrops there I would I'd be like all
right I don't wear red don't wear blue
you know just stay neutral this would be
the worst
shirt to where when I was in Eaglewood
all Earth Tones and beige and khaki
and but I I understand what you're
saying but it is I'm being stereotype
though yeah but at the same time I I get
it but I'm one of the people I guess you
have to get to know me yeah you know
well that's a same with a lot of what I
was saying too like I'm stereotyping now
like we can't be cold blond because
that's stupid uh and then you can't just
make it the sole identifying Factor
right is is race like there's a middle
ground like recognizing the differences
and like that isn't what defines you
it's the same thing with anything
whether it's you know sexuality
orientation it's like okay that's a part
of you so when people are like I don't
see color it's like so I know you're a
liar like that's not true but you also
don't want to be like all black people
all white people and I know the iron is
not lost to me I just said white but
that's largely true um it is a it's a
weird uh it's a weird time where you
kind of have to pick one of these two
lanes and and neither one is necessarily
helpful and uh it's a it's just it
really is often like I will tell you
this my interactions with generally
speaking like if I hold a door open this
will happen everyone will tell
especially after like me to air the me
too air if I hold a door open for a
black woman you're just like thank you
if you hold if I if I hold a door open
for a white woman either they don't say
thank you like I can do it myself it's
like I didn't mean to ruin your whole
day like that you know I was just trying
like what do you think I'm you think I'm
trying to sexually assault you hold the
door open like I have better
interactions and this is what we one one
of those like I have better interactions
generally speaking with black women than
white women specifically just because
you can talk and they're not looking for
a reason to be offended all the time
those are your experience I have those
experience on both sides I think that's
up R again sure uh the way you was
brought up and the way you are cuz I've
held the door open for a black woman and
she just walk on through and I'll be
like okay well you know H do for a white
woman and she done the same thing so
but white and black have said thank you
as well but some some women women period
if I hold the door open and they don't
say nothing I okay well yeah you know do
like I'm sarcastic yeah what's her what
were your names my name is Maya Maya I'm
Jasmine J nice to me I won't I won't
shake your hand the mouse and stuff in
there mess up but okay let me ask you
Maya if you're just sitting there like
you're just going about your in the day
and a man compliments you like says like
oh you have you have beautiful skin or
oh I like your hair does that make you
uncomfortable at all no see most white
women answer yes now no it would not
that's my been my experience like I will
specifically hold back compliments with
white women and I mean I say because I'm
not one going to compliment like a white
black dude you know unless it's his
teardrop tattoo but that's very good
work you should let your artist know but
um yeah I will hold back because you
will get some it's a 5050 sh they'll get
mad right and that's just a thing comes
from you know maybe more traditional uh
views of kind of decorum and chivalry
where it seems like black women even if
they don't appreciate it aren't offended
by it like white men have to they walk
on eggshells all the time now where
that's a big reason we want to talk
about it like let me okay let me ask you
this and this is just it's just a
statistical reality why do you think
that 70% of suicides in the United
States 70% are white men
like considering because we often people
think they have it really easy but it's
just they're twice as likely to just off
themselves as black men it's crazy
high honestly I believe sometimes
stability is one one of the biggest ones
honestly because they have such a um
Prestige way about wanting to be the
upper class I would say put it that way
and um like when it's hard times a lot
of people I won't just say white but a
lot of times black people come from hard
times and white people kind of out
sometimes I won't say everybody yeah
because you have a different life
experience but just from an overall
World Spectrum yeah you it seems like
when it gets a little harder it's hard
for
them I think that's part of it I think
that's part of it I think and the
pressure of the family because there's a
lot of PR dealing with the family V the
man of the house you know what I'm
saying not just the man but the provider
you know what I'm saying everything is
for him no definitely I I think it's I
think it's that and I think it's
combined with the fact that I mean like
you know we talk about sort of white
because a lot of like modern feminism is
spearheaded by sort of American maybe
Canadian white women where it's check
your PIV Check Your Privilege shut up
you're a white man there's no way you
can have anything going on that's a
struggle exactly um and they don't have
the same Community like I think one
thing that maybe black people take for
granted compared to a lot of white
people is like this does this isn't a
thing right for a lot of white men and
so what happens is they feel ashamed and
they feel isolated from those pressures
and they just feel like there's no way
out and well I better not complain
because I'm a white man so you know I
must have it easier than everyone and
it's and it's a stereotype with the
pressure as well you know to have so
much pressure as well and it seemed like
that's kind of overlooked but if you
really look deep into it you can tell
that that's what it is because even just
from their upbringing most of the time
they're pressure to get the best
education get the best you know the
highest paying job or making sure that
your family is taking care of and like
you see it in your own home as well a
lot of black people don't see that in
their home so it's a difference you know
unless you make your mind different and
want to do something different honestly
do you mean you think it's like because
if when you talk about the household
like if if something goes wrong or they
fall short that it's automatically sort
of placed upon the white father figure
you think that pressure where it's like
it's his fault yeah yeah yes yeah I
think that's a big part of it and at the
same time it's not just in movies but
does that you're saying that's not the
same in in Black households is more most
time it's either a one household or the
dad takes care of if it is a dad in the
house he might take care of but you hear
complaining you hear different things
going on behind the scenes yeah it's not
always a happy home it's just like you
see it you you identify it and this is
what it is you know yeah either it's a
one mother home and she's doing
everything herself and or the father in
the home he's always working and she is
responsible for she worked as a yeah
yeah yeah it is a St why do you think
that is you say it's either like a one
uh one parent household do you think a
lot of times people don't want to
responsibility they want to live their
life they might start off acting like
they want to be a part of it but this
it's like the immaturity of they're not
mature enough to really put their needs
last instead of putting them first they
can be a better person a better father
or a better mother you know but if they
put their knes first everybody had a
choice because I could be a mom and be
like I want to take care of my kid you
know that could be a choice but somebody
else might be like well I I can I'm a
dad I don't want to take care of my kid
you know and that easily but a mom can't
leave that e most of the time she's the
one who's chcken K do you think it's
both though cuz this is one thing in
talking with with people like you will
hear um obviously a lot of black women
talking about fathers who don't want to
take responsibility but if you talk with
black men sometimes they'll say well no
wait I do but it's a system where
sometimes they don't want me around
right um and it's a child support and
alimony thing where I want to support my
kids but I don't want to support a
lifestyle um that isn't supporting the
kids so they do you think there's truth
to both sides of that there is there is
some people take advantage but the ones
who really need it don't but there's
always going to be a a a group of women
who take advantage of that and that's if
you're rich or poor well see that's a
balanced view yes which that's like in
the white commit you don't generally see
that you would if I were to ask a white
woman like no it's it's only the men who
are dead beats who are losers oh and
then if you would ask a lot of white men
they'd be like yeah I'm a piece of
and they get brow beat you know they
just they just take it they take it they
do they do they often do it's said and
and that's not healthy I know it's not
healthy you know just can't I I can't
put myself in that man's shoes but it
just feels like the weight is the weight
is really on here White people yeah in a
black community the weight is really on
the mother yeah yeah yeah I mean think
of how many songs right come out of it I
mean Tupac was always rapping about his
mom I don't really think yeah I can't
think are there are there any white guy
songs about Mama I'm sorry Mama from
Eminem but that's about cleaning his
closet like spring cleaning and Sh Mom
I'm coming home right Mom I'm coming
home that's aie Osborne but that it
doesn't have the same meaning I mean if
you look
it yeah that's just silly silly stuff no
that's a good point yeah did it's kind
of more M well what's funny about that
though too is like you're said it's kind
of like more matriarchal like sing
around the mom but I would also say that
that um generally speaking compared to
what like black people both men and
women are are more comfortable with the
idea of like kind of traditional gender
roles like they expect their men to be
stronger who which one black women yeah
they want a stronger man where often
like in the white Community it's kind of
like stability and being more sensitive
and sensitive and right stability
sensitivity everybody wants ability but
that I mean even look at all the
athletes they're always with they're not
with their culture they go for another
culture right yeah because they grew up
wanting
stability they have nothing in common
right they don't speak the same language
yeah but stability and some athletes
just beat the sh a girlfriend in
elevator that's because they're weak too
whoever went for the weak man went for
the weak woman too cuz none of them
strong enough to keep it up right here
both right here no matter how much money
you have do you think that's something
that um you think that's something
that's that's lacking just in general
like the idea of hey being a strong
because it doesn't mean that it's my
view is it's sexism to say like a strong
male figure like masculine role and a
strong mother female role but you
compliment each other and now it just
you know that's a big struggle right now
where a lot of the roles just seem
completely Blended where it's not a team
a partnership do you think it's a little
more clear in the even you know sort of
discounting or disregarding the single
household you think that's something
that maybe is more clear in the black
community as far as like okay you're a
man I'm a woman and we're okay with that
yeah yeah it's clear honestly I came
from a mother and a father a two parent
home but I still feel like my mom did
the work my dad did provide but he was
more like the disciplinary and she was
more like the home taker home caraker
and the mother and the you know
everything well that term is relative
because you know if you had two black
parents they were both more
disciplinarian than a lot of white
parents in 2023 I mean I go I go to the
mall I see black mothers with their kids
and what what like can you stop they
have them on leashes and Sh and black
moms were like you better stop the kid
knows and they get right in line there's
not a lot of discipline in the white
Community right now with with kids um
yeah okay I see that eye roll right so
you you see that right absolutely and do
you think that it's a it's kind of
lacking it's a good thing to have more
discipline with kids more traditional
discip
oh absolutely uh I remember when I was
in school like when you actually get
paddled oh yeah yeah yeah so I mean it
wasn't just the parents it was actually
you know just any adult figure in your
life and it started with the teachers
because you're at school all day long
now I mean you you look at a kid wrong
and they're gonna call the police on you
so it's
just I don't I don't know where I don't
know where that started to fall by the
wayside as far as far as the
disciplinary uh portion uh within the
home and with and within the school
system I mean it's like I feel like it
started there and then gradually the
kids kind of figured out oh well we can
get away with this at school maybe we
can get away with this with our parents
too so yeah that first kid that called
the cops on their parents and then it
just kind of went my the way side from
there like I mean what happened to
parents actually being able to I mean
I'm not saying physically abuse them but
I mean yeah keep them in line yeah go
outside pull that switch off the tree
yeah bring it back here cuz I'm going to
beat your ass cuz you know what you did
uh I we need so much of that it would I
think there would be so fewer problems
just in the world in general if kids
were disciplined yeah seriously I
remember CU you know I was I was a
little and uh also was you know raised
in in a very white area of Canada and uh
they told us they had that whole
conversation you know no no one's ever
allowed to touch you or spank you and so
they said you call you know you call CPS
and one time I threatened my dad I was
like I'm going to call I'm going to call
Child Protective Services he just looked
at me said no you're not was no you're
not and he made me pick my wooden spoon
uh and he but he was I would tell you
this what I do appreciate about my dad
was he was very um I think the balance
is you know I have two-year-old Twins
and so we have to kind of figure and
they're at the age where they're so
sensitive that like you know just even
like putting them in a chair in a time
out that it works you know what I mean
but I know at some point if they're like
me that's not going to work certainly my
if my son is like me like I would get a
timeout when what I'm going to my room
and playing Super Nintendo like I'm
didn't do anything right but the balance
was I know that with my dad he would
make me pick my wooden spoon and I'd get
spanked like depending on the offense
you know um one spank or like three
spanks you know and I'd have to do it
and kind of take it like and then after
that though it was over right and my dad
and I were really close we're really
we're still like best friends to this
day but I still respect them I feared
him but that's why we were close my mom
occasionally like I could tell she was
mad like a little part of was like I
think she's enjoying
this and that I think bothered me more
whereas I knew my dad didn't like it
like my dad didn't want to it's like you
can't do this you know you just burn
down half the shed I have to discipline
you whereas my mom like don't talk back
well she's French like don't talk back
to your mother and like like oh this is
going to sting but not that not that
either of them ever like cross the line
but um yeah I think as long as it's not
done in a way that's like an emotional
thing it's just this is a consequence
thing and now explain exactly why you're
doing it you know I I love you but
you've done this and this is the
consequence to what you have done but
just let them know I still love you but
I gotta do what I got to do you know do
black parents do soap in the mouth do
they do that did she do it yeah that
would be like if you you know dirty
words but they did it with my brother
one time cuz he was my older brother and
he convinced me that I was adopted now
everybody does that my brother did my
little sister everybody crying no he
like convinced me I was adopted and to
go like find my parents like he helped
pack my bag you know that's how my
brother used to act and my dad I
remember he grabbed a bar of soap he was
like now what you just did is the worst
thing you can possibly do to your little
brother that's worst that's that's an
awful thing to do and so I'm going to
wash your mouth out so you never speak
these kinds of things again like okay
and uh he never did it again at least
not when they found out you know like
but yeah and then uh it definitely is I
would agree with you on that and it's
just like if I were to say this like he
was just talking about say this on
campus with you know predominantly um
upper or upper middle class like white
people particularly women they'd be this
right here would horrify them hor I
can't believe that's abuse it's like
there's a difference between if we can
all agree that beating kids is bad right
disciplining kids is necessary exactly
we can't even have these conversations
this is kind of goes back to the idea of
how
isolated
sorry we not leave here with a perm this
isn't on is it no I'm going to leave
looking like house party um but uh we
can't even have these conversations a
lot of the time like in the white
Community just because it's like
disagreement is just boom cut off we're
very
segmented I don't understand what's
wrong with having an open conversation
me and you can agree to disagree but
just have the conversation people be
uncomfortable with the conversation
believe yeah they don't want people
don't like real conversations they want
to hear like something that's going to
make everybody feel better yeah yeah
that's not going to offend anyone that's
not g to make anybody ruffle any
feathers everybody's going to be okay we
don't have to talk about
that it never changes if you don't do
you think some of that extends though
too like to for example from we're
talking about like kind of between white
people but like from the black community
to the White Community a little bit
because white men have been browbeaten
as everything is racist for so long that
they're just afraid to say anything I
mean do you think that there's some of
that like at what point do you think for
example if like I'm you know a comedian
um and so one of my good friends Nick
depalo he's like one of the best ever um
he did a show with a guy Patrice O'Neil
who died too young he was kind of poised
to become like a Dave Chappelle and all
they did was just for example racist
jokes that was their show you know it
was everything like you dirty Guinea
from and he was you know and then of
course all the racist could say towards
a giant 350 lb black guy but they were
really good friends when do you think it
crosses over or is it like in the realm
of Comedy because that's a big
conversation I mean you see it even
happening with Dave Chappelle from the
lgbtq AIP side but that's kind of become
that's kind of something we've seen from
white black for a long time where
there's this policing of entertainment
and of Comedy where do you think that
kind of ties into an open
[Music]
dialogue I'm not even honestly I'm not
even really sure I don't listen to a lot
I don't really listen to a lot of
communi but I always hear the the
Fallout I hear the afterwards yeah so
uh that's their form of expression so I
feel
like like if you a comedian you know how
his jokes go it's up to you whether to
sit there and listen to him or not yeah
you know what I'm saying because
somebody can get offended but you know
what he might talk about what she might
talk about so if you go there and you
get offended you know
they're human just like that's just Prof
you're there to laugh so if you're not
there to laugh you should be there yeah
yeah what do you think about like people
saying like that was a racist show so
this guy needs to be banned no no that's
just you shouldn't the show and you have
to just sign a waiver when they get
their
tickets like this might be some
offensive language you know yeah and you
have to ban like 90% of black comedians
let's be honest but it will make
everybody to make their own decision
whether they want to show up that yeah
no yeah that's right but that's not what
we're really seeing like the problem is
now they're trying to say oh H I don't
like what this person said so no one
should be able to go and see them well
yeah that's like Dave Chappelle you know
or venues I mean I got um you know I got
in trouble of this just they're like oh
you can't because I do Impressions and I
do impressions of black people
celebrities at what point does that
become appropriation like so it's okay
to do an impression of Donald Trump but
not Cat Williams
oh like does that seem like is that is
that some people try and say that doing
an impression of a black person is like
black face I was just about to say that
is totally not the same thing if white
people for years it's like be funny yeah
oh yeah every every time every black
comedian's white guy voice is like this
and like don't sound like that but it's
funny so that doesn't like that doesn't
offend you not at all then why do you
think that why do you think that's such
a big deal in the media because this is
this is why we do like this because the
media they always want chaos no they
want to have control that's what they
want they want they want to control the
people on what they said they want to
have the power so it's to me it's all
about power because they behind the seen
sing jokes of racist jokes you know they
are they're not gonna sit here and say
oh yeah you know you're doing it we're
doing it too right no they're gonna say
you're doing it you know what you need
switch your language we don't like it
they go back in the back room and talk
about what you just said a l yeah I feel
like and this is my ignorant white
opinion if I were listen in the media I
feel like there's there's been no group
of people when I I was it dawned on me I
was watching CNN and like
MSNBC I said there's there's never been
a group of people who are so over
represented in media uh than black
Americans today without being
represented at all in the sense that if
you like to look at the percentage it's
like you know 35% of CNN and they're
black but it's Joy Reed and it's van
Jones and that I'm I'm sitting there
because again I've been in green rooms
and stuff with Comics like the sh
they're saying that this is what the
black community is bother like that's
not that's not at all what I hear no you
hear what I said they wanted to be in
control if it's not
true I mean it's just like how they say
people cheated with the votes even if
somebody want whatever they want is
gonna happen you know what I'm saying so
it's not even about what even if people
say could you see the crowd coming
people are there to hear you laugh so
for them to say something other that's
almost like the sky is brain yeah but
it's really B well yeah they just want
to start want to divide people for sure
um and that that is something div
exactly yeah they absolutely do like
like van there's no clear example than I
don't know if you know do you know van
Jones he's see this is a perfect example
all liberal white people know van Jones
like oh my God van Jones he's such a
great voice to the black community and
then every time I ask a black vers like
who Ben
Jones and uh he was on CNN just this was
like in the last 24 hours so there was a
republican debate and uh this guy v r
he's a an indian-american guy and I like
I'm s I'm like oh this is a kind of
thing that he said that would actually
like black people be like that's funny
so you know Chris Christie big fat guy
that they on the stage he said yeah he
said he said you know he said no one's
voting for you he said so why don't you
just walk off the stage go have a good
meal and like settle down I was like
yeah see exactly and Dan Jones the CNN
he's like I was so offended by this I'm
literally shaking I'm like I can't
imagine a black can you imagine a black
guy saying that here not at all like you
were shaking that someone the fat joke
to another dude God yeah
no we end up probably looking at them
crazy like really yeah okay I think it's
trending right now right now van Jones
like this is ridic this is ridiculous
he's like this is I was shaking I was so
offended like I Can't Tell You Like
Comics if you go into a green room like
you put on a few pounds you have a black
you fat fat mother like that's a like
it's right away like that was I think
that's where there's so many good black
comedians too like when people talk
about we need to you know like
affirmative
action there there's one place you don't
need it first off I think that that's
racist saying we need x amount of black
people we need x amount of women x
amount of white people but if you look
at like the top 10 list of comedians of
all time top five everyone's going to
agree on Richard priar the Eddie
Murphy's the Dave chappels right like
there's a huge percentage of black
people now no one said we need this
amount of black comedians I think a big
part of it comes from this a culture of
talking of you know busting balls like
for sure like they they're they're okay
making fun of each other M um and that's
one thing to me that I just sit like
well when we talk about like how
everyone's underrepresented like okay
we're talking about the NBA we talking
about the NFL what about comedians like
that's a perfect
meritocracy black people are tend to be
funnier than white people just because
white people like that's I'm basically
saying van Jones is white when he says
I'm shaking I'm so offend like that
sounds like something my liberal Uncle
would say like white guilt uncle that
does not sound like anything any of my
black guy friends would ever say well
then tell him has he had bias triceps in
your y can see you got busted up he
wouldn't be offended he got he was just
offended so that's what made him act
like that yeah he he that was his
defense makm to be the victim there you
go do you think that's a big thing that
the race to be a victim like the victim
mentality this trending right now look
at everybody who's coming FL with every
allegation about all the famous people
and this and things that's going on
everybody wants to be known as the
victim like fls me but you made all the
decisions you
made when you went you know what see
inter that you bring that up I was just
thinking about this I think you're
talking about like the me too stuff some
of that right we can all like beating
kids is bad rap is bad right I think
just to be clear like is a bad thing we
all agree but considering that okay like
uh okay it doesn't take a genius like if
you listen to to Hip Hop or like you you
know you watch bet like like sex s in
the black community of course right like
white people didn't invent twerk him but
there are far fewer accusations that you
see from like you like famous women
against famous black men I mean you go
back like to Mike Tyson but it's just it
was just this huge rush of white women
and then there were some that were
horrible like Weinstein that guy
deserves to die in prison but then there
was like uh a he had a bad date you know
I mean like that's a big thing they're
taught in college that if you regret sex
afterwards it's even if you consented do
you think that that's also like a
problem now that that cuz I tell you
this men are afraid
to
date cuz like they don't want to be
alone with a woman but particularly
white women do you think that there
particularly yes yes it is you think so
what there's particularly white women
yes yeah I don't I don't never heard of
a it's all light
wom mostly I'm sure there's like I'm
sure Kelly well he was Ping On people I
mean entirely different they let him
it's not like it's I heard of they let
him do that I don't even understand how
that works not to get dirty oh my no I
don't know
she oh let me tell you no I remember
when I first heard about that I was like
okay cuz look like when a guy is aroused
there's a there's Hydraulics at Play
It's You Can't PE exactly how do you how
do you you have to get yourself soft in
order to to do it which is what turns
you on right that's terrible yeah I okay
but
I'm it doesn't make any sense anyway
take but
so so you think did they deal with
archia because it was so gross I don't
remember all of it did they consent to
it all the girls sure I never watch I
just I don't I don't think all of them
did no I think some but I don't remember
the yeah the number if he was like
surprised on someone's face that's bad
yeah like if she just like walked out of
the bathroom and he's
like you know that's that's a problem
but if they consented it doesn't matter
how weird it is you know I mean mean
like there stuff it's like hey that's
not my thing right right that's how I
feel yeah because like you can s to and
then now he is in trouble you know well
he might deserve it he might but what do
they deserve it I'm gonna move with see
closer because I can't now sounds like
we're on the Titanic with this thing
going um there was yeah I'm trying well
Bill Cosby do you think Bill Cosby did
it
that's that's
man yeah
I what he really liked was yeah I'm
sorry I do think that I think that some
of those were definitely not consens
yeah Prett sure I didn't hear about it I
mean I heard that he did stuff but I
didn't hear that he I don't like
listening but he was just like America's
darling every everybody whing like he
was like the crossover everybody L Bill
Cosby so he could do no wrong so I think
that's just why he got away well you so
nothing anyway well and I say he got
away with it for so long and then
somebody you know they finally decided
to join together and step up speak out
or whatever but you see how long it took
to actually convict the guy or I don't
even know did they did they convict him
no he's away with yeah so it's like well
here's the thing is I don't I mean I
think he did go to jail for he did go to
jail but then there was like an appeal
was a whole his thing got overturned
gotted yeah I mean I think that maybe
it's it's to know right but what is
interesting to me is if you were to say
this to in any group of white people
that all like oh absolutely he did it
like of course he did it um I think they
were just gun him because he again
because he could do no wrong he was just
this overly uh sophisticated powerful
black men who did no wrong and just had
so many white friends who were I mean
that was just you had white friends
powerful white friends oh you were you
were you were something
they knock him yeah he did don't you
think there's a statue of limitations
for a reason like you can't if it
happened you can't come out 40 years
later right that's I mean that that's a
problem it is I mean cuz you can't you
can't prove that if it's false you prove
you can't prove it's true now it's just
the media yeah it's just he said she
said it I mean and your who your mind
has changed everything has changed so
who you to say if you can remember
exactly unless you went to your diary
and wrote down and you can go back and
yeah well that's what happened with
probably put Brett kavanau was a supreme
court uh justice and of course everyone
this is the one thing I like I'm I'm
conservative like Christian conserv so
people will say like oh you're racist no
matter what if you vote with white
people like that's why they'll just
looking in Justice Cavanaugh I like
first they tried to say he was racist
then they tried to say that he um he rap
like that's how they tried to block him
from the coming to Supreme Court Justice
and first off this woman who made it up
Christine blasy Ford she um her story
that she gave to the Washington Post
didn't match up with her story to the
cops the story to the cops didn't match
up with the story to the friends and the
house that she claimed uh where she was
didn't exist and the other people said
that never happened and then Kavanaugh
had Diaries and they looked at his
journals and his journals matched up
like all the other journals which it's
like okay you know June 24th he said he
was going here and they could see it
from a yearbook or from like his
athletic schedule where you know he
didn't write going to gang someone in
his journal he wrote the opposite and
they go you know what it seems like this
checks out but that was the attack they
were going to use politically and some
people still believe it some people
still believe it just because he was
accused of it I mean sometimes that's
all it takes just to put that out there
just to uh you know carnish the name
because and once it's out there it's
kind of done deal it's sad I think this
also goes back to the idea of you know
like we talked about like white suicide
because you said like okay Bill Cosby
and I think you probably did some of it
but I think that for sure like white
people in general are more likely to
jump on board yeah guilty you think many
black people in general whether it's for
a black or white per are initially more
skeptical right let's wait I think
there's a bit of a like if Johnny Depp
was black he wouldn't have had his life
ruined until we all found out about
Amber her his bed you know what I mean
like I think lot people like I don't
know she sounds crazy right there's two
sides to this absolutely but that guy
lost everything yeah right everyone she
just said oh he did this there was no
proof right and he lost his Disney
contracts everything until we got to
court like oh my God this woman's a
Monster yeah that was that was a good
thing though and that that just showed
that women can be cruel and and just as
ignorant as anybody else men so yeah
just to to so I was actually very happy
I like wow she said all that and and
that's another problem that I feel like
men um are are hesitant because women
lie so EAS easily about whatever and
they believe it yeah you know and
everybody oh because she's the weak you
know one and he's the you know the more
dominant one that's not true at all
that's very stereotypical so yes I was
very happy I also think that um it's
funny to say but like black people as a
community tend to be more uh forgiving
than white people in a lot of ways like
like in other words okay Johnny Depp you
have had an alcohol problem I mean like
so okay you can be a drunk and weirdo
and not be a domestic abuser you know
what I mean and I think people like oh
listen to this tape where he's he's
drunk and he's like cussing at her he
must be guilty well now we know that she
threw a bottle at his head before that
and broke his finger but everyone was
just so quick like oh he's he's an
alcohol he must so he must be bad
whereas I feel like often like hold on a
second two things can be true no one's
perfect so let's wait and I think that
maybe maybe that stems from obviously
like when we were definitively more
racist country the kind of idea of sort
of it's like a public lynching with your
reputation now you know I mean they kill
your name they do and I wonder if it's
just black people like n I've seen this
before I'm not going to go along with it
until I get a little more information
yeah cuz I feel like black people
honestly they have to be convinced yeah
do you hear what I'm saying no I think
yeah that's why they follow Trends they
have to see it first you know what I'm
saying then they get everybody see
everybody doing it then it's like okay
I'm do yeah so the same way with
decisions or anything like that you know
they want to hear the whole story cuz
most of the time you are so right
because they want to they're so in tune
they want to hear the whole story
because they want to know what happened
right A lot of times white just off the
bat just from what they heard you right
yes yeah they'll go they'll go right to
oh okay you must be an animal I mean you
think of uh like you think of I mean I
think he did it but like oh I mean I
mean come I think he especially after he
wrote the book if I did it um but I
think that it stems from and some of it
was just like Hey we're skeptical
because it could just be this the famous
black man where you know could just be
trying to effectively I use the term
Lynch him meaning like destroy his
reputation um and that's you know that's
a lot of scenarios where I think they're
probably is today more value in that
because people are so quick to just they
use the term cancel um do you think do
you guys is that something that you
think is a big fear like the black
commit can I tell you like white people
are terrified of either getting accused
or
cancel yeah I mean that's a benefit
right to like last person you you get
you have more leeway
yeah not much but yes well definitely
more like in the black community I was
just listening I was just listening to
like here I was just listening to uh
like prior and even I'm sitting like oh
my God you just switch this to from
white to black like you're immediately
done you're immediately done and it's
funny yeah it's funny but yeah that's a
big thing now people are afraid to talk
in the white Community goes back to
dividing what do you think like what do
you think is
the what do you think is the best way
forward because I will tell you this I
grew up this is kind of why why we
started doing this is I grew up uh I
grew up in Canada and I was born in
Detroit raised in
Canada and I feel
like I don't just feel but statistically
I grew up in what would be considered a
post-racial uh America North America
because I was in Canada but like the
biggest shows were fresh prins Family
Matters the biggest stars at that point
were I mean the biggest film stars were
Will Smith jzo Washington um obviously
The Cosby's and now
it's almost like here's Black
Entertainment on this channel and here's
White Entertainment where now it seems
like there's more of a racial divide
than there was when I grew up and I
don't mean as far as policy as far as
you know like Jim Pro laws I mean as far
as I think people they been told that
there's racism so much that people are
actually just more afraid to reach
across the aisle do you think that's
that's true that's my feeling from the
white I would with that yeah
I can't answer cuz I don't
know got to look at it but I
mean you saying like different TV
networks have different shows black
people what I'm just saying is like when
I grew up it wasn't like I again we
didn't have that many um black kids at
my school where right GRE up we had a
lot of and most of them were Haitian in
Quebec because it's a you know Quebec is
a French Province and it's a French
Colony so a lot of immigration but we
had a lot of Asians and a lot of uh a
lot of Middle Eastern people Arabic
people and we didn't even think of it
growing up but we just hung out and it
wasn't really like a big deal and now
when you have classes people are being
taught like white kids you check your
privilege and you're being taught about
racism so much like we were taught about
slavery we were taught that it was wrong
we were taught about the Civil War I
said from up North I'm from up North too
so it's different than it is here in the
South I don't think they ever taught
people that slavery was good no not the
slavery I'm talking about the privilege
like far as the mindset of different
things is a difference between up north
but do you think though do you think
that's a a good thing though to be
instilling in children like checking
your privilege and making like good
thing yeah because I think you're
creating racists when you do that you
are but there's there are ways to to
teach and not to make u i but it kind of
stem home as well the privilege you know
and if then it goes to the
SCH no it's part part of curriculum
sorry is it part of curricul oh go ahead
well no no I I just I feel like like as
far as te teaching the slavery I mean or
teaching about history and whatnot I
mean you want to to teach people about
things so they don't repeat it but you
don't have to to U brow beat the kids
like I mean because you're white you
know you're an evil person right you
just want them to know what happened
this is what happened and we don't want
that to repeat but I don't really feel
like yeah kids are innocent like you
said when you were growing up you know
you played with whomever and whatever it
wasn't even a big deal but and then once
you once you start to put that in their
minds then they're like oh well maybe I
shouldn't do this maybe I shouldn't play
with that person or whatever I just feel
like that I feel like that how do I want
to explain that it's
like I just feel like te when you teach
them teaching them in a way that won't
um that won't cause them to I don't know
to to in to in a way be racist because
yeah
it's like you're teaching them racism U
well imagine you're a little white
you're a little white kid and you don't
know anything about but you're taught
immediately and by the way it's also
inaccurate to act as though slavery was
exclusively an American white problem
like that's just that's just not
accurate too it happened it still exists
today like there there are more slaves
right now in the world today than ever
because most of them are sex slaves so
we just sort of because we are all way
more privileged in the United States
where we don't have slavery black and
white we don't realize that in Asia in
the Middle East in Africa slavery is
still a way of life and it's not based
on race it's based on whoever you can
subjugate you know I mean that's where
the slave trade started right was was uh
West Africa and North Africa like we
talked about this uh not too long ago on
a program there were there were over a
million you know white Mediterraneans
who were just kidnapped off a
Mediterranean coast and enslaved like a
lot a lot but they weren't just
enslaving it started in Africa so a lot
of slaves were black but they also went
to the Mediterranean and enslaved
whoever they could find um and sold them
and that was a big thing you know think
about it the United States of America at
this point slavery is everywhere and uh
it's the biggest export effectively from
that continent right from the African
continent and you want to end it but you
can't at that point because everyone's
took the bloodiest war ever to end it
and largely white people but white and
black people fighting hand inand you
know what I mean like everyone makes
mistakes but to then instill into and I
see this and I'm worried as someone who
has young kids white kids where I don't
want him to be made to feel guilty for
something he had nothing to do with
because I know that if you tell him hey
you're basically garbage because someone
did this hundreds of years
ago that's a problem that's gonna create
more racism exactly yeah that's a
problem school yeah I'm talking about
yeah in school if you do that and you
say hey you you you need to you know
atone for the sins of your your great
great great forefathers like all of a
sudden as opposed to being that kid
who's hanging out with people of any
race watch
people of any race on TV you're going oh
there's a separation here and uh I must
have done something wrong because I was
poor and white and we see that now where
there's definitely I do think racist
sentiments have gone up just not in the
sense that they support slavery but just
people are afraid to
talk I agree and that's something that
we we run into quite a bit so it just
seems like there's got to be some some
sort of a middle ground though yeah you
know and but finding it that's that's
the finding that sweet spot of actually
just
teaching about history but not again
making person feel like trash because
their forefathers whatever you know did
whatever whatever I mean we're all you
we all make mistakes it's like if we all
taught if we all T taught Real History
yeah I mean I think we would all give
each other some Grace well I think yeah
I think you're right and I think I do
think that you know since public
education which has been a huge failure
by the way on all fronts white and black
but it's been largely run by white
people um they've done kind of what you
were talking about divide people uh and
try and say hey hey hey hold on look
we're going to give you this black
community we're going to do affirmative
action or we're going to teach about
slavery and we're going to make it all
like 75% of Southern whites own no
slaves that's a huge huge majority right
it's very small and by the way there
were there were black Southerners who
owned slaves too absolutely so when you
do that first off it's not honest and
then you create a division that is just
going to perpetuate more racism and I
tell you what I do see it with younger
people now um more than I saw it in my
generation where they're either just
completely guilted and they're afraid to
talk about anything or they go you know
what screw this screw you I'm not I'm
not gonna be made to feel like I'm
racist just because I was born white um
that and that's not good on no both both
situations are bad nobody's talking and
it's it just creates more divide sad and
public education is terrible it's awful
it's a real problem and no one actually
wants to fix it it's not a money problem
too there's plenty of money it's just
it's not going to the right place yeah
it's going all the private schools I
don't know if that's the answer either
uh I know plenty of kids that were priv
that went to private school and they're
just as screwed up as the people who
went to public school yeah well that
happens too you know sometimes it's ugly
things happen in pretty houses a lot of
people think if you're wethy that you
must not have problems but just comes
with different problems in a lot of
private schools but we've talked like
we've talked about with public education
the idea of school choice which just
means cuz right now let's say you
average and this County let's say it's
let's say it's $115,000 per student
right what you spend tax dollars if you
just average out the number one of the
solutions that's been proposed out there
and I always talk about this right I
don't know how anyone can disagree with
this is rather than just send the money
to the school where they get it no
matter how they put fund is attach the
money to the students meaning hey this
is how much we spend per student so this
student has this credit to take to any
school that they want to if parents want
to drive them or if they want to get on
a bus or if there's I mean here you have
so many schools that are close together
right sometimes you're closer to the
school you're not supposed to go to CU
the county lines just we're going to
attach that to the student and all of
you Schools public schools still you
have to perform better because if you
don't they're not going to go to your
school that's a solution out there that
just seems to me like it doesn't change
the funding even at this point we're not
even talking about changing the budget
just talking about instead of just
giving it to a school and these teachers
and these administrators we're going to
give it to the student to take whatever
the parents want yeah they won't like
that because it's going to force the
teachers and the the uh academic
community in general to actually do what
they're supposed to do right because if
all the kids want to go to school a and
you got school B sitting over here with
nobody like oh my God nobody they're GNA
lose all that money people lose their
job blah blah blah whatever so I mean
yeah it forces people to step up so I
totally AG that it's funny you because
we're not allowed to criticize teachers
in the white Community they're like the
teachers you mean the true heroes it's
like I kind of thought those were
firefighters well I think the role of
teacher has changed ially over the past
decade or so because now they're
training teachers out a shooting class
and I'm just like flabbergasted at how
different it is to actually just be an
educator or even be a student in this
day and age just having drills you know
for Shooters active Shooters and all
this crazy I I can't even I can't
imagine what do you think on that what
do you think about having people though
at schools like um not only armed guards
but if teachers are qualified to be able
to have a locked firearm to protect
their students I think it's a good thing
I think it's a really good thing because
we have seen in in various uh videos
that have surfaced that uh security
guards aren't all that qualified or or
do the appropriate thing yeah look at or
actually run the opposite way things
happen so yeah yeah that's yeah that's
what the the vality thing was just that
was
uh it was the hair and like I was filled
with rage yeah like oh on we can't it's
a risk it's like kids are dying in that
room you signed up to be a police
officer it's not just to give out
speeding tickets this is what we pay you
for yeah no that's a big that's some
that's been proposed where um you know
people say oh that's that's encouraging
more shootings by allowing people
teachers who are again we're talking
about teachers who want to have firearms
right not making
it yeah no no you don't want to give a
gun to someone who doesn't want itely
but if someone is a teacher who's
qualified and has a permit and anytime
they're outside of school they're
carrying a firearm and they have one in
their car why wouldn't they be allowed
to in their profession they're allowed
in a lot of other professions of course
has to be locked of course you have to
have just like everywhere else you have
to be responsible but I don't think I
don't think we'll see that in our
lifetime because it's a pretty
cost-effective solution to start with
it's not the full solution all right but
it's a step it's not going to happen I
mean it it'll maybe happen in some
municipalities but see this is the thing
this is why these like I tell you I go
on Camp and I talk with kids or you know
if I have a debate on air some like they
act like all this is crazy but we all
disagreed on like you can't have
teachers with guns like why why not
everybody else has a gun why can't they
have one yeah if they choose to
right yeah especially too like you know
I think a big problem too that we in my
generation was black lives matter and
then the the police kind of thing and I
will tell you this not a fan of
certainly the organization black lives
matter I mean kind allow the woman just
bought like her third multi-million
dollar house
um but I also didn't say just back the
blue period because there is corruption
within the police force now I don't
think that the biggest problem that
police force is you know just pulling
over black people and them being racist
I think the biggest problem that police
force is like you talk about teachers
where it's not performance-based they're
not trained properly um and a lot of
them abuse their Authority Leu valdi was
not wasn't a race thing no that was a
police problem and if we all just said
okay we can all agree on this problem
with the police as opposed to making it
just a race thing right now like let's
start with this and instead what
happened right away is we go right to
racist police and it's like well then
you just divide the conversation breaks
down and uh yeah I'm not I mean I think
police officers have a tough job but uh
there needs to be some reform people
have it worse actually are black cops uh
like my dad's from Detroit Detroit
proper the worst city in the country
take the worst area of South it's not
even close the house he grew up in as a
kid just sold for
$8,000 a fullsize house in downtown
Detroit fullsize house yeah he grew up
in a very very bad area um and black
police officers in Detroit they'd have
to drive them home in unmarked cars
because they were being killed in such
high numbers during the uh Detroit Riots
think about that that's got to be the
worst job in the country at that WR
time what do you think we need to do on
on that front like as far as police
reform
I am so sorry no that's fine I I I just
I invaded your while you were getting
your haircut no you're fine I just
unfortunately I'm I'm doing something I
shouldn't be I'm working I'm I'm working
while I'm while I'm getting my you're
doing something you shouldn't be Oh I
thought you said doing something I
shouldn't be I'm selling
crack yeah no no a matter of fact I
don't have to be on that so I was I was
just making sure I wasn't missing a
meeting oh anyway now I'm sorry what was
your question okay if you're a white I
would say selling meth but heroin bridge
is The Great Divide both black people
and white people want heroin so that's
let just all take some heroin and we'll
sort it out um no police reform like
what do you what what would what what
how do you think the black lives matter
thing I say thing because there's the
organization and there's the idea that
okay Justice right and and making sure
we have good policing how do you think
that overall affected you know not only
black but relationships between the
white and black I think it help that my
just about to say the if black lives
matter even I'm black they do matter but
all Liv do matter and I know we have
been through so things but everybody
everybody's generation have been through
something I feel like though sure and I
feel like God created is all equal
though no matter what when he looks at
us he don't look at black eyes white
eyes chines he look at us as a right so
when I see stuff that divides and it has
cry before it it always prob com before
a claw yeah so therefore anything with
CED in front of it it's never going to
be sustainable it's always going to be
Ser level Stu it's never going to be
like really deep because nobody wants to
go deep right yeah yeah so so you
wouldn't say that it's racist for
someone to say all lives matter no oh
see you have you have no idea you have
no like the van Jones exactly these
people in the media they would say
that's a that's a dog whistle meaning
it's coded language for white supremacy
if someone well yeah I think black lives
matter what but I think all lives matter
they would say that's racist because
you're telling black people that their
lives don't matter as much no no I'm
saying all lives matter but to start
with it implies that only these lives
matter and I got to tell you I've only
heard that it's racist from white people
you just said the phrase I have
literally been told that is racist I
said of course black lives matter but of
course all lives matter not just black
lives like that's
racist that's because that's what people
want them to hear that's what they want
to hear yeah so people
say eggshells
you going to be persecuted yeah oh even
my oh oh yeah no you're black why how
could you say that because right there's
all lives on this Earth yeah and they
all do matter what do you think is the
biggest what do you think is the biggest
like misconception that white people at
large might have about the black
community
wow yeah
I'm huh well because you know you hear
people say like like oh they stereotype
or so that seems like a place like what
do we think is the biggest maybe thing
that white people get wrong about I'll
tell you what is the black community
using this term right I understand like
Loosely is that we already touched on
that the idea of like white privilege
that all white people must have it easy
or that there's no you know there isn't
the struggle because there are a lot of
different kinds of white people just
like a lot of different kinds of black
people
um but I wonder what what it is that
black people think like if they could
correct something like no no no no okay
look General white population let's get
this straight
right
huh I'm trying to think of one thing
that really sticks out that that white
people get wrong
um I guess that means they get it mostly
right yeah
well no there's I would say uh that we
are always looking to
um um how do I want to how do I want to
phrase that well or maybe that that that
most most black people are are afraid of
white people I don't I don't think that
that's true at all yeah I I
think just because of everything that's
happened you know uh police brutality
racism blah blah whatever I I feel like
I feel like a lot of uh white people
feel like or or that we're angry yeah
the angry black person yeah we're not
angry I don't think or that we all live
off the system right yeah and a lot of
white people live up the system you
saying but we get stereotyped as the
ones who are so poor that we live off
everybody just has babies and Liv off
the system so many redneck white trash
people shouldn't say that
but yeah we are not the only ones like
if if you go down to the office you see
a
majority people well I think it's fine
if you say that as long as CU I
understand that you're not saying all
white you are saying there's a specific
subset of white people you know these
towns lived in Michigan so there are
some towns that are destroyed by Meth
you know just destroyed by Meth like I
know exactly who you're talking about as
long as it's also um I guess I should
say not permissible but you also afford
the same Grace to a wife white person
saying I'm not saying all black people
but there are some ghetto hood rat
whatever ter like these people who do
actually live off the system they're not
saying all black people just like you
don't mean all white people are white
trash but there is a subset in both
communities who look they don't they
live off the system their entire
lives so that doesn't offend me at all I
I know the white trash people I have
them in my family not my direct family
not my direct family uh everyone though
in French Canada and the extended family
mullets and 69 sorry 89 Camaros like
it's it looks like Joe Dirt um they
don't have drug problems but yeah as
long as it's Grace I'm not joining not
joining what a meeting that I was
invited to join okay not joining it you
probably get nervous if a white guy
looking like me said I have to go join a
meeting like it's gonna be a clan thing
isn't it no you see going to breakfast
meeting no coffee and
danish danishes I
haven't yes absolutely no I think that's
um I think that's so how about so like
okay let's take that not all black
people live off the system a little bit
and not all white people live off the
system right I would say the approach is
okay now there are statistical realities
as far as who uses the system and how
the system is abused um the solution is
to reform the system period whether it's
white people or black people now if that
disproportionately ended up affecting
black people because they're let's say
that depending on the state too it
really does depend on the state it does
depend on the state because Texas don't
yeah like if you go to West Virginia
you're going to have a disproportion
number of white people using the system
right but if you go to you know certain
areas of you know Houston or something
like that or South Central you have a
disproportionate number of black people
using the system so as long as we just
look at it this system needs reform like
what do you think about for example like
welfare um or whatever it is okay uh
basic drug
testing would like get drug tested have
them be have people uh get drug tested
before Oh I think that's a 100% great
thing okay absolutely yeah you don't get
this check if you're just getting high
absolutely I am all for that that's been
proposed it's been called racist but I'm
just saying well I'm saying drug test
white people too right how is that
racist we're drug tested everybody again
because there not just it's not just
black people who are on welfare oh my
God or or the solution that okay
obviously if let's say you have uh
social safety nest if you lose your job
right unemployment okay but if you've
been on the system for a long time okay
there are government jobs that you work
you work and you get a check so you
don't just collect a check because
you've been doing it now for let's say a
year two years three years you go work
this job and will place you into a
private sector job but now you have to
work to keep receiving a check that seem
seems fair to me I mean matter of fact
it's giving them a leg up you're giving
them a job yeah I mean versus having to
go out and find one yeah yeah it's a
win-win to me I mean there's so many
jobs that don't require a lot of skill
or education like in the government like
answering calls filing papers it's like
okay well now you can't just collect a
check forever we helped you when you
were down but now you need to per just
work it's a drug test and just work
right absolutely that's just the system
in general I it doesn't matter if you're
white black Asian I don't think there a
lot I don't think there are a lot of
asian-americans who use the system
though to be honest they don't I don't
think there are a lot of them on welfare
they I say are there that's a probably a
0.00001 percentile if that comes from
that comes from a culture of like pride
and like you do not take that money your
mom will beat the out of you yes yeah my
my lawyer's Asian his mom his mom taped
soap in his mouth and jammed piano keys
in his neck because he played the wrong
note yeah tiger mom's a real oh and it's
so sad because there are so many
stereotypes or or jokes about that uh I
can't even I recall something was it
family guy or something like that it was
a little Asian guy in the room studying
and the dad comes in talking
about he said you Doctor yeah he like no
I come back when you doctor come
back well there are some look I think we
can agree that some stereotypes stem
from some kind of Truth obviously and
that's for white people and for black
okay first all a lot of Indians around
this area you notice that like this is
something I noticed cuz they come from
countries a lot of them where they don't
drive they don't have cars they put
student driver on their car have you
seen this and it's like a 45y old but I
appreciate that are you see I've never
seen that oh you've seen it right yeah
it's everywhere here but I have but I've
never notice because a lot I guess a lot
of people have tinted windows or I'm
just not paying attention as I pass by
but I have seen a lot more student
driver stickers yeah student driver
stickers you know what though I
appreciate it because they're basically
saying you know I know I can drive so
keep a white cut the white swapped I
will say that I was actually almost
sideswiped by an Indian uh maybe about
two three months ago out on a bike and
they yeah it was a wa he was on a bike
no I was on the bike he was in the car
and I almost got Sid swiped because he
literally couldn't drive so and as we
raced to follow him when he went into
wherever he finally
parked what I don't
understand yeah yeah really oh no you
understand
you almost killed me but you're trying
to play that maybe he didn't he didn't
understand his GPS she was talking to
him and he was confused yeah but no a
big okay so that comes down to like
we're that's not because of the color of
the melanin and your skin that does stem
from like a lot of these a lot of these
people I say these people come from
countries of their first generation
immigrants but they don't have cars they
don't drive you know so no it's true
yeah especially there are a lot of
people come in here you know with the
tech jobs from India right now or
Bangladesh and uh and there certainly
not used to the crazy Texas freeways
like this you know um so that's a big
reason why it's just like for a lot of
the same stereotypes that you see with
black and white people you're like well
that's not because of the color of their
skin there are sometimes cultural
differences the food that we eat you
know the kind of entertainment we
consume it's like no one's saying it's
because you're black and you're white
we're sitting there these communities
where we have differences and that's I
think a difference between a stereotype
that's actually racist versus ah if you
come from a country where you guys don't
use cars it makes sense that you might
not drive so much
especially you look in China like they
have those like Honda Cub scooters they
have like 19 family members in a chicken
Coupe going uphill come on you've seen
that right on a motorcycle yeah like
yeah they'll have
a that was so funny that was my first
motorcycle with that you know that's the
most common so it's it's called you
probably know it if you see it it it
it's not like a vesa it's it's kind of
like a middle ground between a
motorcycle and a scooter um where it's
still like the bar go hybrid the way cuz
we don't see them a lot here it's the
most sold vehicle of all time the Honda
cut it's like 65 million sold because
it's we don't think of it but all over
Asia and these things are indestructible
like you can put vegetable oil in the
end and it'll work um yeah and unlike a
scooter the big reason too is because
they put so they carry the stuff around
yeah it has um it's below the CC
requirement because of like Smog and but
it has three gears so you can still use
like the first gear you know and go
uphill MH you know with your whole
extended family and a couple of cows in
the saddle bags they don't sell those
here though do they um they do they just
re-released it but it doesn't really
make a lot of sense in the States you
know because you need to be moving these
things have a max speed of like 40 m
hour um yeah it's not it's not even
worth on the side streets I was thinking
yeah it' be nice you know just to kind
of get around the neighborhood but now
people are flying doing 50 including
myself on these side streets so it's
yeah not even worth it scrub that if
that's on camera we all go the speed
limit yeah my dad uh my dad last time we
were actually he mentioned SMU campus we
were uh driving back from SMU and my dad
was in the car I had never heard of this
before he got hit doing I think he was
doing like 45 they said hey man the cop
goes just so you know like cops can be
to white people too and uh he goes hey
you have any reason you were going so
fast my dad goes I going I going like 42
he goes this's a school zone my dad says
at a
university these are
adults it's like those are grown ass men
cop's like ah you want to get smart with
me he's like just give me the tickets
like just that's I had never heard of
that that's funny so I don't know maybe
if he was black he would have been you
know on the hood with his cuffs saying
ah you got anything in your pocket but I
just think the cop was having a bad day
but if you go to SMU know that there are
speed limits now or
TC yeah and those are TCU and SMU um
are very privileged schools so
absolutely they're going to you know
like just make it I just think extremely
difficult around those universities I'll
just say that well I just think no one
so they can make more Revenue ABS oh
yeah as if they need any more but yes
yeah exactly well yeah that's the thing
too is right when people talk about
defunding at the lease that's a problem
but we also need to look at where the
spending is going like hey how about
before we go to defund cuz that's not
good that's not been good where you
don't have police that's not a good idea
but what are we doing with the money you
know it's it's not
great it's not great it goes back to
what you're saying about them being
educated and and trained properly if
there's no money to do that then GNA the
police they are they don't want to be
that the people are have evil in their
hearts they've been trained too well
some police there a lot of not everybody
yeah I'm talking about the one who is
the ones who ain't is who they are
they just put on a uniform well those
are the ones that don't need to be
police offic but I mean how do you how
do you they TR K people for innocence or
anything like that not just black people
but anyone does this surprise you this
is something that a lot of do you know
that um actually uh when you're talking
about being shot by the police that uh
specifically white men and if you're
dealing specifically with armed white
men like white men are many times more
likely to be shot at I believe did you
know that really
way more likely yeah there's there's a
disparity between armed and unarmed um
and so a lot the stat is like unarmed
black men are more likely to be shot out
of police armed white men are more
likely to be shot out of lece so both
have a gun a big reason though too is um
unarmed black men are more likely to
assault a police officer and that is
true that is statistical reality I'll
tell you this uh I saw it right here
just a um it was a corner of Parker it
was a corner of par ER and Midway and
there was this this I'm sorry it was a
female officer and was a very large
black man and it was and I watched and
it was a black man he was obviously high
too like he was you know and this woman
was terrified she had no business I'm
sorry she had no business like I do like
female police officers like you can't
meet the PT requirements like you should
be dealing with a giant black guy in PCP
this guy was like six foot five and he
didn't have a shirt on it's just of his
boxers
and I think I have it on my phone and I
could see him too CU you
know I could see the body language I'm
like a shots coming shots com he one
like this he kind of put his hands
behind his back you know he did this
thing and like the light woman was I'm
sorry to say so dumb the top she was
like okay this is good he's gonna come
peacefully and then just boom and he
just she took it like a champo she
didn't go down and then they tased him
um but statistically is they are black
perpetrators more likely to and that
could also be byproduct of you know
drugs in certain communities more likely
to physically assault an officer so
there's a disparity there but as far as
armed white men are AR black men um
white men are more likely to be shot and
a police officer is 16 times more likely
to be shot uh by a black than a black
men from a police officer and that
includes black police officers that's my
problem with black lives matter and then
one side black lives matter one side
back the blue well hold on a second what
about the black lives of these black
policemen cuz there are a lot of black
policemen and we need them we need them
because I think a lot of them say hey we
need some kind of police reform they had
bad police in their community and uh
they say I want to improve it do well
but I've spoken with a lot of black
officers and they go yeah this is a
thankless job it's a thankless job now
because I'm being demonized as a black
police officer like it's I'm on one side
of it and I hate my community it
couldn't be further for the truth and
that to me was really sad I think it
also um it kind of erods away at the M
office yeah because it you know over
time they just they start to say it
and I've seen some bad black police
officers it's like bad white police
officer but when I see them on tape the
the the black officers it it just kind
of it hurts me a little bit more yeah
just I mean I am a black woman so it's
just man I just I thought we were better
than this but I mean they're human just
like everybody else is so I mean they
need reform just like everybody just
like the police officers or the ones
that have the issues here so it's the
one that really breaks my heart and I
and I'll end with this because I think a
lot of people don't know this you
remember um well really the first hands
up don't shoot was Mike Brown right not
Mike Brown the officer I'll say this
because Mike Brown assaulted that police
officer with his own gun A lot of people
don't know that and that guy um Darren
Wilson was the name the police officer
so a lot of people because there are bad
police officers right you have you have
certain ones where you're like okay
clearly this was a wrong shoot but that
one was used his hands weren't up he was
reaching into the police car he had hit
the cuff taken his gun and was beating
the out of this officer Darren Wilson
and Darren Wilson actually um he
specifically he was actually given a job
in a pretty easy area and he said no I
actually want to be here I want to go to
Ferguson because I think that we have
bad policing and we need to build trust
between our police department and the
black community like he was loved in
that Community he was one of the good
officers
and that was an example of a story that
was just people were force fed a lie a
complete lie and you saw what happened
with you know with Ferguson after that
in Missouri like I think if people knew
that truth they would go okay let's take
a step back because that guy's life was
destroyed I was going to say whatever
happened to him like probably in hiding
somewhere I guess because I'm sure he
got a jillion death threats or whatever
so and you lose a good cop y you lose a
good cop not saying there aren't the bad
cops but people don't know that story a
lot and it was used as a lie where hands
up don't shoot and again if you said
hold on a second hold on a second this
is not true you have people shut you
down go well are you a racist you're say
no no no no no I'm saying that this is
not the example that you're talking
about um and that one if if ever you get
some time I look at you know Darren
Wilson and and read up on him that guy
was really vilified um when he was
trying to do the right thing that guy
was torn up too you didn't want to have
to shoot him what do what do you do
though when you have a guy reaching for
a gun reaching into your car beating the
out of
you so Mike Brown
and he was a big dude too is the air on
probably not it's hot Travis is the air
on um he was a big dude and he he was he
was a
criminal yes or
no can you turn turn it up a little
bit literally yeah hot as heck just ad
on the high seat that's all yeah heat
RIS
it's hot back
here it's it's know the song say getting
hot in here yes but I'm not taking
anything off about say you heard what
Nelly
said not not today not today sir I have
a theory about Nelly I have a theory
about his Band-Aid oh you know what it
is what I think cuz if you look at Nelly
back when he was a teenager he had bad
acne I think he had a bad zit and he
covered it up with his band-aid and I
was like what are you wearing a Band-Aid
for like no this is my new style thing
I'm doing the Band-Aid thing and then he
had to stick with
it I have no I have no factual basis for
that it does make sense it does you know
why I thought that cuz I tried it when I
was a teenager I had a really bad Z and
I was like a I fell off my bike
oh um that's f s were you asking me
before uh I think we're talking about oh
yeah Mike Brown Mike Brown he was big
yeah he was a big dude big dude a lot
bigger than Darren Wilson and you know
that day he had just he had just uh you
know knocked over a liquor store he had
stolen the shopkeepers he he just he
saled a the the shopkeeper and then got
into an altercation with the officer
Darren Wilson and uh yeah reached for
the guy's gun and hit him in the head
like black black big dude though and uh
that officer was uh he was there because
he wanted to be there he wanted to be
there and he said hey we don't have good
trust in the black community so I want
to serve this community and they loved
them before that right but the media
picks it up and a lot of people don't do
their research and it becomes hands up
don't shoot his hands weren't up he was
in the car beating the guy grabbing the
cop's gun oh W now I think when we talk
about that the solution so like this is
an unpopular opinion I love chokal now I
mean actual chocal because I come from a
submission wrestling background the
problem is if a lot of cops like they
only learn their hand to-hand combat
they do it once and then they're police
officers for the rest of their lives and
so if you don't actually know how to
handle somebody physically you have to
go to your gun
right so I think they they should have
guns obviously police officers need guns
we're not like the UK where they have
billy clubs and they just they just get
just get mobbed they can't do anything
um but a lot of people the problem is
they say okay we don't want police
officers to have guns we don't want them
to have tasers and I say we don't want
choke hes we don't want okay what do you
now what do you do what do you want yeah
and I don't mean now a choke cold just
be clear and we actually did this on the
show where I was like cuz this is
something I don't know do it a I've been
choked up many many many many times it's
in the sport oh so jju like Judo yeah
it's a sport it's like it's like
wrestling but it's a choke or it's a
joint lock choke does not drowning it's
not suffocating it happens in 3 seconds
it's your blood gets shut off and you
just go to sleep you don't even feel
pain you feel like you ever fall asleep
in
class feels just like that um if applied
properly so it's actually the safe you
don't want to have to get punched
knocked out hit your head off the
concrete you don't have to break
somebody's arm you don't have to tase
them so that gets malign where people go
oh this like with when we're talking
about George Floyd there was no choke
that wasn't a choke that had nothing
there nothing to do with a choke but now
police officers can't use that at all
and so they have to go to their gun they
should be training it hand in hand just
like teachers who need or want a gun I
think we we act as though all violence
is bad and it's not like how are you
going to subdue a violent criminal
what's the least harmful way right not
shooting them
obviously but you know this would be
considered sexist and they should have
regular training as well think about it
I mean annually hey we're going to let's
let's refresh because maybe you forgot
or let's just make sure that you know
what you're doing so do you have to
renew your license at all like to for
like a beauty license every how often
every two years every two years and
what's the test
like the first we have one initial test
so it's not bad it's a um hands on and
then there's a practical now so okay and
you have to that you have to show that
you're confident every couple years yes
yeah we just have to do a five hour
um uh I would say information of course
so we have to do 15 minutes of sex
trafficking and then you got to do five
hours of just continue education will
you say sex
trafficking
okay this you're gonna have to get what
yes we do was it because there's a lot
of sex trafficking and I don't know they
just want us to be aware in case someone
sits in our chair and maybe you know
trying to show signs or something that
there is this news to you it is I was
about to ask
you just said it like it was like you
just listing off your breakfast on since
sex trafficking got really popular so it
became a part of it wasn't always a part
of the curriculum so they made it made
okay I will say that with know not to
get off on another subject but yes I've
heard of the the sex trafficking here
like more
recently just blown out of proportion oh
yeah or maybe they're just shining a
light on it no no it's it's horrible
well okay so that brings me I know I
said I was going to go but I is I like
having these I usually talk to ask
that's my problem so I'm like oh I want
to talk for a long time uh sex
trafficking is because of really the
problem that we have in the border right
now like a lot of illegal immigration
people again turn that into a racist
issue we need to either close down the
Border we need to make sure that we know
he's coming into the country um because
it's a problem big problem with that is
the have record number of uh sex uh
traffic mean sex slaves sex slaves right
now it's it's unheard of what do you
guys think about that or gals sorry Z's
if is gender neutral now um what do you
think about the board issue immigration
in this country like do you think that's
a problem that needs to be addressed
yeah absolutely I I'm all for people
getting a chance to to live the
so-called American dream that we're all
living so so abundantly here uh but I
just feel
like there are so many issues that we
have with the people that are here again
I'm not against people coming in but I
mean let's do it it the legal and
correct way why do we have all this
sneaking across the border and blah blah
blah and and I mean and some of the
people that that do that they actually
end up being you know decent citizens if
you want to call them that because
they're not technically the US citizen
but you know they they uh they work and
contribute to society you know that's
great but I mean then there there are
those that do not yeah so but again we
don't know that because you're sneaking
over illegally it's
like yeah yeah it it see I think if
you're being honest here that was the
first time when we were you you were
like oh I gotta be careful what I say
right you're going not some people who
come here legally because you don't want
to be accused of being racist right
right that's what white people have to
deal with all the time all the time like
I don't mean to say uh all all black
people I don't mean to say all but what
I mean it like that's the problem I I
think it's completely self-explanatory
you're not talking about people who come
here legally but I don't think there's
any racism at all in saying you're
coming here illegally we don't know who
you are you could just as easily be a
sex trafficker which many are or you
could be a decent person we don't know Y
and it just so happens that it's at the
southern order so obviously
disproportion are going to be um
Hispanic but uh that's not why you have
a problem with illegal immigration if it
was happening in Canada You' probably
the same problem i' be a bunch of
obnoxious white people Canadians are
obnoxious I think we should close the
Canadian were all nice and wonderful and
seen our Minister have you seen how many
times that guy's done black face no no
seriously have you no
not he does it more than any he donees
it like 15 times we actually every time
we do a story on the show we go oh the
Prime Minister had this to say we just
show one of the clips of him and
blackface go oh sorry wrong clip just
because I want everyone to know that
that guy did it so many times he would
go to sports games and paint his arms
and legs black oh he went black body not
black face
he it's almost like a fetish like he
would do it all the
time cuz he's a uh and now of course he
goes out and now he's the most
Progressive liberal like he literally in
his speeches in Canada will say and I
want to discuss this with our uh and he
will say this he will say gay lesbian
bisexual transgender uh asexual and
two-spirited
Community to Spirit that's a one okay
now see liberal white people go like
yeah sure to Spirit yeah yeah like we
know no it means it's a Native American
version of like
pansexual means so you you're not
actually transgender your spirit is
multiple genders wow I just explained it
and it still doesn't make sense to me
what yeah so but now so in other words
so people forgive him right because oh
he's he's on our side in Canada this guy
did blackace so many times like when you
think of Megan Kelly I don't know if you
remember Megan Kelly she got in so much
trouble where she got fired from ABC NBC
M they said she was encouraging
blackface did you actually hear her
quote she just said she said well I'm
not talk like blackface minstral shows
she said but like when I was a kid I had
friends white friends who dressed up
like Diana Ross for Halloween with the
hair and like because they love Diana
Ross she said is is that racist and they
that's why she got fired wow the exact
quote was talking about she had a white
friend who dressed up like Diana Ross
and she said I think like that obviously
means they loved Diana Ross they weren't
trying to be racist they just wanted to
dress up like Diana Ross you know why
cuz she spoke up you know why she spoke
indirectly up you know she didn't say oh
you know everyone should just love
everyone she just said I had a white
friend that dressed up like Diana Ross
so she spoke too much if she would have
just been quiet and not even address the
fact that she even had a friend who did
that she wouldn't have got fired no no
but that's the problem speak up she to
be afraid like oh it's something as
simple as that Y and it seems like
there's a picking of the right people
it's like okay you did blackace 15 times
but you say the right words now so we're
going to leave you but we don't like you
cuz you're you know a pretty blonde
woman and you're talking about that
you're fired now she got because she's
the stereo type of who white people
should be the blonde pretty white girl
so you hear another another blond pretty
white girl it's like oh she Diana Ross
she had black you know like that turns
them on their ears up you know to the
point where well maybe she has she's not
racist she's not like us you know it
makes them start going there in their
mind I do always find it funny though
when like someone actually said
something racist like legit and get
caught and that was the Canadian Prime
Minister we I remember I was I was H
myself laughing when this happened so it
came out the first two videos of him
doing
blackface and uh he was at this press
conference and he's can he's just like
when you talk about weak weak white men
it's this guy right and he comes out he
goes yes and you know I'm really sorry
about you know in my past I did uh dress
up in ways that that were um you know uh
distasteful and I did it I did the one
time and uh I'm I'm very apologetic uh
and I apologize to the black community
the whole apology where I have to make
this right okay he thinks he's about to
get off scottf free so he addresses the
one he's like okay thank you very much
and he's about he's walking off and one
of the for goes yeah uh are there any
other times that You' performed in
blackface he's what and he
stops boy and he turns back he goes oh
well there was a there was one time um
at a school talent show uh
where I did perform um uh the banana
song thank you no more questions and he
walk like d said like I have to find
this video like he had to address it
like there was one time when I did full
black face and performed the banana song
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa and you thought you were just
gonna walk off right oh my gosh I I was
peeing myself laughing so hard cuz he
got caught dead to wres and tried to
tried to just shake it off so all right
anyway go watch that if you want to good
laugh oh yeah Justin Trudeau you'll want
to punch him in his smug smug stupid
Canadian face all right I'll let you
continue doing your thing how long do
you have to sit in this chair until she
done with generally three or four oh my
God how long we been talking I don't
know
minutes 90
minutes about another I'm sorry I'm a
chatty
Kathy yeah this is 25 bucks and it takes
me like 30
minutes I know it's not a major selling
point I haven't had my haircut in months
and I got one compliment from a woman so
I'm like I'm never cutting my hair again
I still think I think it works right I
just need to trim this stuff you I need
to clean this up a little bit yeah the
thisis first yeah yeah yeah it's just
because they said you have to grow it
out first and then trim it you know but
I don't know I'll probably cut it what's
your name again my name is Stephen it
was Maya and Jasmine Jasmine thank you
Maya and Jasmine I appreciate thank you
very much my hands are oh sorry I nice
me you thank you appr we have one more
question yeah go question talking about
um immigration and just
uh Mexico in general because that's
where the border is how do you feel
about uh or how do you feel when they um
come over and do not learn to speak
English bothers
me me as well yeah no it bothers me as
well I mean this is a good example of
only in the United States is it
considered racist to say we should have
a national language other countries do
in Canada we have two we have English
and French is also stupid French
shouldn't be one but um yeah that's also
been something so this is it's
interesting that you bring that up
because a lot of people in the white
Community have said we need to have a
language that we all speak they're
accused of being racist don't you get
pissed off when you call to the customer
service line and it's like press one for
English right like I shouldn't have to
press a damnn thing yeah because we are
in America yeah it's exactly no I
completely I mean my mom is French
Canadian and uh she had to learn English
you know she she had to learn English
came here when my dad when we moved to
Canada my dad had to learn French are
you choking are you
okay what I'm fine oh about to get up
and try to perform the
highing grab some water from that salt
shaker looking
thing it looks like the kosher salt
shaker it doesn't look like a tumbler at
all that's my son that's your son a he
graduated last year oh that's okay I I
know you tell me I have okay I have a
since you asked me like what is it what
is it like this is something we don't do
in the white Community what with black
people wearing like shirts with like
that like shirts of people on their
shirts and they'll have like like a
person W white people like it's just
funny to us cuz we never do it yeah
unless it's like a family reunion I was
going to say I don't even think I've
seen one uh within U family reunion a
white a white family wearing anybody on
their
shirt yeah unless it's a gag something
like a a weird Christmas gift or
something like that like a bachette
party it's like her throwing up in the
toilet or something just to embarrass
her I think honestly because we do it it
could be for a funeral birthday party we
really celebrate you know what I'm
saying and you want to remember the
person and they feel special on your
face is there that's how my daughter
feels I have a 12-year old daughter she
wants her F on her cake she wants her
face on her shirt she just happy at
funeral they do it for remembrance okay
and they put the person's face on a
shirt that's just always yeah but then
they keep wearing the shirt yeah that's
like 3 weeks later Quick
Trip yes they will I've never been big
on that though I don't wear that people
on
like I don't unless some
money there you go that's example just a
cultural difference where it's like I
know a lot of people want to ask white
people want to ask the question like I
don't know if I'm considered racist like
this is something that's so foreign yeah
but as a black person it's it's foreign
and strange to me too the way they do
hey who again who am going to say
anything I mean so you're the odd one
out at a birthday party they're all
wearing the shirt of like whatever
Sandra and you're like no I'm wearing a
nice blouse yeah that's me I'm wearing a
nice blouse yeah I was say first of all
I wear no shirt even if they're alive I
don't think I have any friends that
would have a party that would require a
shirt that had their face on it so and
if I had that kind of friend then oh my
God I shouldn't say that I was about to
say I think I would have a problem yeah
I say some people think super seriously
like you refuse to wear the shirt you're
going to end up on World
Star so I that's very strange no I agree
with you on the yeah the Immigrant no
that's something that we all would and
by the way you know house would agree a
lot of legal Hispanic immigrants too
who've learned the language exactly yeah
the most racist person I know it's
hilarious one of my best friends he's
but my booking agent his name is uh
William he's super gay he's Cuban um and
he's super right-wing like he he's gay
but he's like he's like oh my God he's
like he's
like it's why it's so funny it's so
funny like he's like gosh he's like we
what is going on I have a bunch of gay
friends none of these want to get
married he's like what are you talking
about this is and he he really doesn't
like Puerto Ricans cuz he's Cuban and I
go Willi why do you why do you dislike
Puerto Rican I grew up in the new I grew
up in New York in the 70s and everyone
thought I was Puerto Rican it the most
insulting thing in the world do I look
like Ricky Martin or a criminal no I'm
not Puerto Rican I'm Cuban but he's
learned English and he's like I can
learn English I came like my parents
came here on a raft from Cuba to flee
communism and listen to me he's like I'm
a gay Cuban conservative American and
I'm not people need to stop learn the
language go to work so I appreciate him
when I talk about absolutely people
think I'm making you can barely
understand how oh my gosh
[Music]
what Bren I just I I would I would
rather talk to an automated a machine
versus talking to them sometime I'm they
try and fake you out like where are you
from Pros like I'm calling from Savannah
Georgia oh you right just tell
me you're calling from a call center in
Bangladesh where they chain you to a
computer for 9 hours a day and give you
a piss break for 4 minutes and we'll be
fine in this conversation I just don't
want you to lie to me right yeah no it
is it is a it is an issue and it's again
another thing where I think people would
find common ground but every was afraid
stop well I think that we are over
accommodating them because you see well
I mean because there are just a lot more
Mexicans here in Texas everything is in
Spanish now yeah and it's like what why
do I have to learn this to speak your
language when you're in you're you're in
America but again it's just nobody wants
to have the conversation everybody just
wants everything to FL you know nice and
easy let's do this for them they're
making it way to
easy no so I agree with you all right
I'll let you I'll let you go finish
finish up thank you ladies thanks for
the conversation thank you I appreciate
that was fun oh my gosh my eyes are
adjusting now coming out here how you
doing what oh yeah okay all right when
you come from back there it's different
yeah it is yeah I'm just seeing like a
silhouette it's like your eyes have to
adjust so that's my theory on now it's
probably bull but that's I got a saying
that's how rumors get started that's how
rumors get started Lindsay Lohan wrote a
song about
that but she's obnoxious so remember
none of this is possible without you
join the fight and sign up for mug club
today at louderwithcrowder.com mugclub
for $89 annually join the fight at
lc.com mugclub today